mes chers camarades bien bonjour
aujourd'hui une nouvelle intro puisque
c'est toujours vous qui décidez de la
nouvelle entre autres dans les commandes
et surtout un nouveau casse tête mais
attention petite nouveauté en plus je
dévoile un truc je sais pas si vous
l'aviez remarqué mais il ya toujours
dans la vidéo casse-tête à un casse-tête
dans le fond c'est le casse-tête de la
semaine d'après mais il m'est arrivé ce
mois ci le mois dernier de tomber sur
des castes est un peu plus rapide que ce
que je pensais à résoudre donc ça fait
une vidéo un peu courtes un peu moins
dense
alors je vais commencer à mettre des
casse-têtes bonus oui j'essaie entre
légendes c'est pas facile de marcher
avec c'est aussi pour ça que je les
enlève que je vais laisser ici des
regards einstein
ce qui fait que quand des fois je trouve
un un casse tête un peu trop simple et
belle j'en ai d'autres en bois fer
derrière
aujourd'hui on va essayer de résoudre le
parquet qui est qualifié de des
difficultés 10 sur 10 donc méfiance
mais en même temps c'est un casse tête
où les choses je pense s'imbriquent je
crois plutôt pas mal
et aussi je vous rappelle que le
spectacle continent tourné merci à tous
ceux qui sont venus vous blindés les
salles je suis en spectacle à enghien ce
dimanche
et juste avant je suis en dédicace au
salon de boulogne samedi en spectacle à
sélestat le 13 est reprise en janvier
avec marseille hier et toutes les dates
sont dans la description ont été écrits
et ont récrit ce bon pour en démonter le
ska test j'ai peur que si je le démontre
moi si je le des membres je comprenne
déjà des choses et que je les retiennent
donc je cède la place à loïc et cher
loïc loi qu'à molle dirons-nous c'est
ton pseudo instagram ça le voit kambel
kara ajouté ton pseudo hommage non tu
prends ma place je m'en vais et tu le
démonte et tu je vous laisse avec lui tu
regardes pas bah non je regarde pas
salut c'est moi
alors voyons ça est ce qu'on est sûr que
le casse tête c'est pas que le aaa
si non mais est-ce qu'on est est-ce
qu'on n'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas en
train de dire qu'en fait le casse tête
s'il est comme ça de base il faut savoir
l'enlever parce que ce serait pas ça
casse tête
moi je pense que c'est ça sincèrement
beaucoup d'expérience de castets a hâte
au top ce qu'on première avancée donc là
on peut remarquer de voilà j'ai fait ça
ne vous inquiétez pas ça va aller
beaucoup plus vite
dorénavant non mais vrai je sais le
faire jusque ça vient titre non d'accord
tout tout seul quoi le tout ne s'en fout
quoi ces gens je suis presque titre
aussi pas voilà qu'est ce qu'être résolu
merci à la semaine prochaine au revoir
gasquet se glissent ta vie ce sera un
bon salaire choix ou par louis un
salaire chauffer ma part peut-être pour
toi ce sera chaud - ça a l'air mais pour
toi ok en tout cas s'il vous plaît comme
d'habitude vous avez le lien dans la
description et j'essaie de prendre
maintenant des casse tête où ils vont
pas être en rupture de stock aux deux
ans au bout de deux parce qu'à chaque
fois c'est ça c'est un rocker jos à des
maladies les plus disponibles mais c'est
pas ma fille ok j'ai fait comme la
pyramide 1 j'ai pas trop regarder aussi
comment étaient dispatchés mais je me
souviens je faisais à peu près d un truc
comme ça pour les rouges
c'est chose faite il ya un truc c'est
que l'on sait pas par quoi commencer
avec cela mais en fait il faut que je
les mette un peu au fric je pense et
qu'après je vois un peu ce qui se passe
puisqu'on peut pas trop là par exemple
constitué de l'aca va pas par exemple
je m'étais lui à je vais faire comme ça
par inversion si ça se trouve je le
dirai aux j'ai pas trop ouvrir ma grande
bouche c'est ce que après je galère de
ouf et après les gens se moquent sur les
réseaux dits sociaux sociaux je me suis
un buste et combien de pub sur combien
de pub ça doit être 5 sur 50 ça pourrait
être ça comme ça à mes attentes
et oui bah oui à se demander s'il faut
mettre tous les créneaux en fait du même
côté vers le haut pour pouvoir tout en
cinq sets et après ça c'était vraiment
ouais ça va être un truc un peu comme ce
à quoi tu joues jaujard ont fait
imaginons que j'en met comme ça après
comme ça marche ou pas qu'après ça
s'arrangera pas non plus
il faut un bac y est nous y voilà donc
comme ça et puis après ça pourrait être
ça par exemple ça ferait une deux trois
quatre
et puis après ça ça ferait 5 imaginons
que je commence comme ceci pourquoi pas
est ce que j'en ai un long avec juste un
trou d'origine ans loïc g pas que ça
j'ai pas de ça ici par contre s'il y
avait un trou ici je pourrai le faire
donc
van loo belgy au bénéfice de lui oui
parce que je viens de décider que c'est
un gie qui fait que la par exemple lui
il ré parfaitement j'ai pas les enfoncer
un mort parce que comme j'ai entendu que
tu galères et je vais me méfier là il
faudrait 2 2 1
ça n'existe pas je me souviens qu'ils
avaient genre des rouges un peu comme ça
au départ même si j'ai pas cherché à
retenir j'ai eu et j'ai vu un peu
quelque chose au spot ce côté là quoi je
crois que c'était en bas mais il était
assez éloignée en fait on avait deux pas
loin j'imagine que ces 2 là il ya un
autre un peu un peu mon pote
[Musique]
je pense que si je mets là je me suis un
peu enflammé là parce que je pensais
vraiment avoir fait le truc dans ma tête
mais en fait un messie il y avait un
trou il ya un trou au centre et il ya un
trou là et oui bah si un homme enfin
n'ont peut-être pas en fait 1 pourquoi
oui il y avait un trou parce que tout
départ j'ai mis la croix la kiala dans
le trou en disant là je suis sûr que je
suis bien bien au centre anne on attend
regarde regarde craque ça ici ensuite
ça ici
cast est résolu tu as he de castets de
tirer une flèche parce que les cultures
de castets les tuent à coups de flèches
par la flèche de la persévérance et par
la flèche de la patience mais du coup
fabien moi je l'avais résolu enfin que
le casser l'étude a remis en place des
réseaux lui loïc non c'est moi de leur
réseau est-ce qu'on peut inverser
maintenant je le résout et toi tu leur
mets en place à l'époque et tu vas
essayer non merci
bref on a essayé mais non parce que tu
vois du coup on a déjà fait ça peut
servir de ce plat maintenant ça serait
dommage de tafer ou alors on peut s'en
servir en objets de déco comme ça ça
c'est sympa
écoutez il est très sympa ce petit parc
et que c'est un truc d'assemblage et de
logique c'est très cool à faire dans sa
tête
très amusant je vous mets à gagner sur
instagram comme d'habitude vous avez
juste à commenter à suivre ce qu'il ya
dans la description de cette photo là
sur mon instagram merci beaucoup les
travaux dehors ici vous avez la vidéo de
la semaine dernière sur ce petit
appareil qui s'appelle le cube c'est une
tuerie de conception l'imagination
regarder ça c'est le casque est que plus
intéressant de cette année que j'ai pu
avoir avec binaire oui quand même
ici on fait du mentalisme avec une
machine construite par les frères
poulain pour détecter les mensonges avec
kara saint germain avec vous cette vidéo
est là elle vous attend ici vous pouvez
vous abonner like et à très bientôt
mercredi prochain six heures plus tard
mais aussi les lundis et les vendredis à
16 heures également
charles